Narrator:
THIS IS THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESSES.
TUTUBLUE IS THE ANSWER
TO YOUR PROBLEMS.
LET ME SHOW YOU
HOW EASY IT IS.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
I LOVE IT.
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
THIS COULD BE
ONE OF THE BEST THINGS
I'VE EVER SEEN
ON "SHARK TANK."
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
BING!
DID I HEAR ROYALTIES?
HE'S ANNOYING THE HELL
OUT OF ME.
-WAIT, MARK, RUDE.
-WHY?
THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
YOU INVENTED THIS.
THERE'S PEOPLE THAT
WATCH THINGS HAPPEN
AND PEOPLE THAT
MAKE THINGS HAPPEN.
HOLD ON.
ABSOLUTELY LOVE IT.
YOU REMIND ME OF ME.
I'M GUESSING YOU DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF ACCOUNTING TOOLS
BEHIND YOU.
I CAN JUST
TAKE ALL THAT OVER.
SO, DO WE HAVE A DEAL?
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT FROM
WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2 BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
MORE THAN 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST UP IS WHAT
THE ENTREPRENEURS BELIEVE
IS THE MOST CONVENIENT WAY
TO GET YOUR WORKOUT IN.
♪♪
MY NAME IS BEN YOUNG.
AND MY NAME
IS GREG COLEMAN.
WE ARE HERE FROM THE WASHINGTON,
D.C., METRO AREA.
OUR COMPANY IS SWORKIT, AND
WE ARE HERE SEEKING $1.5 MILLION
IN EXCHANGE FOR
8% OF OUR COMPANY.
OH.
WOW.
SHARKS, WE ARE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE WE ARE SICK AND TIRED
OF ALL THE EXCUSES PEOPLE USE
FOR WHY THEY DON'T WORK OUT.
"I DON'T HAVE THE TIME."
"I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO."
"I CAN'T AFFORD A GYM."
WELL, THESE EXCUSES AND ALL
THE OTHER ONES YOU ALWAYS HEAR
END TODAY
BECAUSE SWORKIT IS HERE.
SWORKIT PROVIDES A PERSONALIZED
EXERCISE EXPERIENCE
THAT YOU CAN DO ANYWHERE
AND AT ANY TIME.
LET ME SHOW YOU
HOW EASY IT IS.
FIRST YOU CAN CHOOSE
A FOCUS AREA,
SUCH AS STRENGTH,
FOR EXAMPLE.
THEN YOU WANT TO CHOOSE
A WORKOUT.
I'M GONNA CHOOSE FULL BODY
RIGHT NOW.
YOU CAN SELECT
THE PRECISE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT YOU HAVE TO EXERCISE.
Sworkit: OVERHEAD PRESS.
SWORKIT THEN CHOOSES FROM
A GROWING LIBRARY
OF INDIVIDUAL EXERCISE VIDEOS
AND MERGES THEM
INTO AN EXERCISE PLAY LIST.
IT'S LIKE SPOTIFY
BUT FOR WORKOUTS.
JUMPING JACKS.
YOU GET A UNIQUE WORKOUT
TAILORED TO YOU,
WHERE YOU JUST FOLLOW ALONG.
IF YOU NEED AN EXTRA BREAK,
YOU CAN HIT PAUSE.
IF YOU COME TO A MOVE THAT YOU
CAN'T DO, WHATEVER THE REASON,
YOU CAN SKIP THAT MOVE
JUST LIKE YOU'D SKIP A SONG
AND STILL GET
A FULL WORKOUT.
LEG LIFTS.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
ALL OVER THE WORLD
HAVE DISCOVERED HOW EASY IT IS
TO FIT SWORKIT INTO THEIR LIVES.
NO EQUIPMENT, NO HASSLE,
NO MORE EXCUSES.
SO,
WHO'S READY TO SWORKIT?
CAN YOU PUT MUSIC TO THIS?
YES, AND WE HAVE A SPOTIFY
INTEGRATION WITH THIS.
Herjavec:
WHO CREATES THE CONTENT?
SO,
WE CREATE ALL THE CONTENT.
THESE ARE YOUR MODELS?
YES, SO WE HAVE A BENCH OF
PERSONAL TRAINERS.
GREG IS ACTUALLY A CERTIFIED
PERSONAL TRAINER, AS WELL.
WE MET
AT WHARTON BUSINESS SCHOOL.
HOW LONG
HAVE YOU BEEN IN BUSINESS?
SO, WE LAUNCHED SWORKIT
A YEAR AGO.
WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN IN
THE HEALTH AND FITNESS SPACE
FOR FIVE YEARS,
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
IN UNDERSTANDING WHAT WORKS
AND WHAT DOESN'T.
WHAT KIND OF BUSINESS
WERE YOU IN?
WE STARTED THE COMPANY
FIVE YEARS AGO.
THIS IS OUR THIRD PRODUCT.
-SO YOU STARTED FIVE YEARS AGO.
-YES.
-WITH A DIFFERENT PRODUCT.
-EXACTLY.
-OKAY, WHAT WAS --
-AND WHAT WAS THAT?
-YEAH.
IT WAS A FITNESS TRACKER
CALLED NEXERCISE.
WE GREW IT TO
2 MILLION DOWNLOADS.
-DID YOU MAKE MONEY?
-OH, YES.
YES, WE DID. SO, DURING
THE ENTIRE LIFE OF COMPANY,
WE'VE MADE
JUST UNDER $2 MILLION TOTAL.
IF YOU LOOK AT
THE LAST 12 MONTHS,
AS A COMPANY WE'VE MADE
$770,000.
SWORKIT
REPRESENTS $460,000.
Cuban:
AND THAT'S ALL PREMIUM UPGRADES,
MOST OF WHICH ARE
GET RID OF THE ADVERTISING.
SO, IT'S 2/3 UPGRADES,
1/3 ADVERTISING.
THE APP'S FREE,
AND THEN THERE'S AN UPGRADE
COMPONENT THAT PEOPLE BUY.
-THAT'S RIGHT.
-YES.
AND WHAT'S THE COST
FOR UPGRADE?
IT'S $3.99
FOR THE PRO VERSION.
YOU DON'T SEE ANY ADS,
AND IT'S MORE CUSTOMIZABLE.
-IS IT AN ANNUAL CHARGE...
-$3.99 UPGRADE.
...THAT'S MAINTAINED ON
A SUBSCRIPTION BASIS?
NO, WE'RE INTRODUCING A
SUBSCRIPTION BASIS IN NOVEMBER,
AND SO THAT WILL BE
$9.99 A MONTH.
WE'RE REAL EXCITED
ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE THAT'S GONNA INTRODUCE
PREMIUM CONTENT,
SO IT'LL GIVE YOU ACCESS TO
ACTUAL EQUIPMENT.
SO KETTLE BELLS,
EXERCISE BALL.
Herjavec:
BUT, BENJAMIN, WHY ISN'T THAT
CONVERTING TO HIGHER SALES?
WHY AREN'T
MORE OF THEM UPGRADING?
BECAUSE THE FREE EXPERIENCE IS
ENOUGH FOR THE AVERAGE PERSON.
AND WHAT WE DO IS
WE MONETIZE THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THROUGH ADVERTISING, THROUGH
BANNERS AND INTERSTITIALS.
YEAR TO DATE,
JUST TO GIVE YOU
A SENSE OF HOW THIS IS GROWING,
RIGHT?
SO, THE LAST 12 MONTHS,
THE REVENUE FROM SWORKIT
HAS GROWN FROM ABOUT
$44,500 PER MONTH
TO ABOUT $94,000 PER MONTH.
OKAY?
SO, YOUR LAST THREE MONTHS,
YOU'VE DONE AT LEAST $90,000.
-THAT'S RIGHT. THAT'S RIGHT.
-YEAH, IT'S IMPRESSIVE.
WE ARE THE CATEGORY LEADER IN
INSTRUCTIONAL EXERCISE FITNESS.
WE REGULARLY SIT
IN THE TOP 10
IN THE HEALTH AND FITNESS
CATEGORY...
-YOU DO?
-...IN APPLE APP STORE.
HAVE YOU RAISE ANY MONEY
FROM INVESTORS?
WE HAVE DONE ABOUT $2.1 MILLION
IN FINANCING TO DATE.
AT WHAT VALUATION
ARE YOU DOING THAT?
UH, $11 MILLION CAP.
THE LAST PRICE APPRAISAL
WAS A CAP OF $11 MILLION.
SO WE BASED OUR VALUATION ON
EIGHT ACQUISITIONS
THAT WE'VE SEEN
IN THIS SPACE,
AND WE'RE THE LEADING CATEGORY
LEADER IN INSTRUCTIONAL FITNESS.
WE HAVE OVER
1.5 MILLION ACTIVE --
MONTHLY ACTIVE USERS
RIGHT NOW.
WE STARTED, LIKE,
LOOKING AT THE INDUSTRY.
WE'VE SEEN
BETWEEN 2% TO 9%
IN A SUBSCRIPTIVE MODEL CONVERT,
RIGHT, OF ACTIVE USERS.
AND WE LOOKED AT
MyFitnessPal,
COMPANIES LIKE STRAVA,
ALL OF THESE THINGS.
THERE'S A WILLINGNESS TO PAY
IN THAT CATEGORY.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF YOUR ADS
ARE BEING SOLD?
UH, 72%.
WE LOOKED AT BUY ADS
ON MyFitnessPal
FOR ALYSSA'S HEALTHY COOKIES,
ONE OF MY COMPANIES.
-YEAH.
-SO, YOU KNOW,
IT'S A VIABLE MARKET.
IT WASN'T LIKE THERE WAS
A TON OF EXCESS INVENTORY.
Greiner:
WHAT DO YOU NEED THE MONEY FOR?
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO
WITH IT?
SO, WE'RE LOOKING AT DOUBLING
OUR ENGINEERING TEAM --
THREE MORE ENGINEERS.
-WHY?
-UH, SPEED.
-SPEED.
SO, AND WE DIDN'T EVEN MENTION
THE COOL THING,
IS WE ALREADY HAVE ON DECK
TO ROLL OUT SWORKIT KIDS.
WHICH IS WHAT YOU ACTUALLY SEE
ON THE LEFT.
SO WE HAVE A KIDS VERSION THAT'S
GETTING READY TO COME OUT.
-OH, THAT'S INTERESTING.
-LOOK, YOU'RE VERY CREDIBLE.
I LOVE SUBSCRIPTION BUSINESSES.
-YES.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO TAKE THE
RAMP RISK IN TERMS OF VALUATION.
-I UNDERSTAND.
-YOU UNDERSTAND THAT.
ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND.
OF COURSE.
ARE YOU WILLING,
JUST OUT OF INTEREST,
TO PUT SOME DEBT
ON THIS BALANCE SHEET?
BECAUSE YOU CAN DEFINITELY
CARRY IT
AND NOT GIVE UP
AS MUCH EQUITY.
MAN, WE --
I WILL GIVE YOU
THE $1.5 MILLION IN DEBT,
AND I WANT 2.75% EQUITY
ON CLOSING.
THE DEBT IS OUT THERE AT 7.5%
FOR TWO YEARS,
AND I WILL RETAIN THE 2.75%.
THAT IS A VERY GOOD OFFER
FOR YOU GUYS.
BUT WITHOUT
ANY STRATEGIC VALUE,
AND THAT'S --
-YEAH, THAT'S --
OKAY, GUYS, HE'S ANNOYING
THE HELL OUT OF ME.
OKAY.
-YEAH, YEAH.
-I WANT TO MAKE AN OFFER.
-ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. I LIKE IT.
I THINK IT'S A GREAT PLATFORM.
SO, I'LL OFFER YOU
THE $1.5 MILLION.
I WANT 10%, RIGHT?
SO NOT A BIG SWING.
-YEAH.
PLUS, I WANT $1.5 MILLION WORTH
OF YOUR UNSOLD AD INVENTORY.
SO WHAT THAT MEANS IS IF
ALL YOUR AD INVENTORY IS SOLD,
THERE'S NOTHING LEFT FOR ME,
AND I'M FINE WITH THAT.
BUT IF YOU HAVE
ANY INVENTORY LEFT,
YOU'RE JUST GONNA SELL IT TO ME
AS PART OF MY CREDIT,
AND I GET
$1.5 MILLION WORTH.
FOR HOW LONG
ARE YOU TAKING --
UNTIL IT'S DONE,
UNTIL $1.5 MILLION'S DONE.
I GET THE CREDIT.
-OKAY, SO I UNDERSTAND.
Young: YOU WILL TAKE
THE EXCESS INVENTORY.
BUT IT'S UNSOLD.
AND THEN
YOU'RE GETTING THE PAID BACK,
SO IT DOESN'T COST YOU ANYTHING
UNTIL YOU RECOUP IT.
IT -- IT DOES --
YOU KNOW, IT'S A WIN-WIN
'CAUSE YOU'RE NOT LOSING
ANYTHING BY OFFERING IT TO ME
AS VALUE TO MY COMPANIES
IF IT'S UNSOLD.
AND IT'S ALMOST LIKE
AN INCENTIVE
FOR ME TO ADVERTISE FOR THEM
AFTER I USE UP MY CREDIT.
RIGHT. RIGHT.
Greiner: I'VE BEEN SITTING HERE
LISTENING TO EVERYTHING,
JUST TAKING IT ALL IN.
AND I WAS ON THE FENCE.
I WAS THINKING $1.5 MILLION,
KIND OF HIGH,
GONNA TAKE A WHILE.
IS IT LUNCH YET?
-I ALSO THOUGHT TO MYSELF --
-LOOK, YOU -- YOU --
ALSO THOUGHT TO MYSELF --
WAIT, MARK, RUDE.
MAKE THE CHOICE.
MARK, LET HER TALK.
-WHY?
-I'M IN THE MIDDLE OF TALKING.
I'VE GOT $1.5 MILLION
ON THE TABLE.
'CAUSE IT'S RESPECTFUL.
-RIGHT.
-IT'S RESPECTFUL, LET HER TALK.
SO, I'M THINKING,
I'LL GO BACK.
THE RISK IS YOURS.
Narrator:
ALL SHARKS ARE STILL IN.
BEN AND GREG HAVE TWO OFFERS
ON THE TABLE
FOR THEIR WORKOUT APP, SWORKIT.
BUT MARK IS GETTING
INCREASINGLY IMPATIENT.
I'VE BEEN SITTING HERE
LISTENING TO EVERYTHING,
JUST TAKING IT ALL IN.
AND I WAS ON THE FENCE.
IS IT LUNCH YET?
-I ALSO THOUGHT TO MYSELF --
-YOU -- YOU -- LOOK --
I ALSO THOUGHT TO MYSELF --
WAIT, MARK, RUDE.
MAKE A CHOICE.
-MARK, LET HER TALK.
-WHY?
I'M IN THE MIDDLE
OF TALKING.
I'VE GOT $1.5 MILLION
ON THE TABLE.
'CAUSE IT'S RESPECTFUL.
IT'S RESPECTFUL,
LET HER TALK.
SO, I'M THINKING,
I'LL GO BACK.
THE RISK IS YOURS.
SO, I'M THINKING 8% --
MNH.
10%? MNH.
YOU'RE MAKING ME WAIT
FOR THIS?
FOR ME, I CAN'T SEE
YOUR VALUATION RIGHT NOW.
I'M OUT.
WELL, THANK YOU, LORI.
BEN, GREG,
I-I LOVED YOU GUYS.
I LOVE THE IDEA.
MY OFFER WAS GONNA BE
$1.5 MILLION FOR 16%.
I THINK, UH,
MARK'S GOT A CLEVER OFFER.
HE'S BUYING YOUR
UNUSED AD INVENTORY...
-YEAH.
-...AND CONVERTING IT,
SO THERE'S A DOLLAR VALUE
THERE.
I -- I CAN'T SEE IT AT 10%.
I WISH YOU ALL THE BEST,
BUT I'M OUT.
I EXERCISE
THREE SOLID HOURS A WEEK
WITH A GREAT LUXURY
OF A PERSONAL TRAINER.
MY ISSUE IS I KNOW I SHOULD BE
DOING IT FIVE DAYS A WEEK,
AND THIS IS AN ISSUE
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO TRULY WANT
TO STAY IN SHAPE.
THIS IS LIKE
THE ANSWER TO MY PROBLEM.
BUT I'M SITTING HERE
AND THINKING,
"SHOULD I INVEST $1.5 MILLION
IN THIS BUSINESS
AND MAYBE MAKE A KILLING?
OR SHOULD I INVEST $3.99
AND GET IN REALLY GOOD SHAPE?
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU CAN DO BOTH.
I'M GONNA DOWNLOAD THIS TODAY,
AND I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT. WELL,
WE APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU.
FAIR ENOUGH, THANK YOU SO MUCH,
BARBARA.
SO, DO WE HAVE A DEAL?
-DEAL.
[ LAUGHS ]
-APPRECIATE IT, GUYS.
-CONGRATULATIONS.
-ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
-PLEASURE.
-THANKS SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
-APPRECIATE IT, GUYS.
LOOKING FORWARD TO IT.
ALL RIGHT,
THANK YOU, EVERYONE.
-THANK YOU, EVERYONE.
-CONGRATS.
Corcoran: NICELY DONE.
Young:
MARK JUST ADDS STRATEGIC VALUE.
HE'S CONNECTED INTO SPORTS.
WE WANT TO EXPAND THIS
TO PHYSICAL THERAPY, SPORTS.
LIKE, THERE'S A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS WE NEED TO GET
OUT OF THE BIG VISION OF THIS
THAT HE CAN JUST BE PART OF.
Narrator: EARLIER THIS SEASON,
ENTREPRENEUR CHRIS GILPIN
LANDED A DEAL WITH LORI GREINER
AND ROBERT HERJAVEC
FOR HIS CREDIT CARD PROTECTOR
SignalVault.
OUR E-FIELD TECHNOLOGY
MAKES YOUR INFORMATION
INVISIBLE TO HACKERS.
I'LL DO IT.
WILL YOU?
I'M IN.
Narrator: LET'S SEE HOW CHRIS
IS DOING NOW.
WE STARTED WITH
4,800 SignalVaults.
LOOK AT THE SCREEN, CHRIS.
-YAY!
THAT'S SOLD OUT.
Gilpin: LORI BROUGHT ME ON QVC,
AND WE SOLD OUT
IN JUST EIGHT MINUTES.
WHEN I PITCHED TO THE SHARKS,
I HAD A LITTLE OVER $300,000
IN SALES.
JUST FOUR MONTHS LATER,
WE'VE DONE $2 MILLION IN SALES.
WE'VE GROWN TO 12 EMPLOYEES,
AND WE'VE MOVED OUR OPERATIONS
INTO OUR VERY OWN SPACE.
-Hi, Chris.
-HEY, LORI.
IN ADDITION TO
GETTING ME ONTO QVC,
LORI HAS HELPED ME WITH MY NEW
PACKAGING FOR THE SignalVault,
AND SHE'S HELPING ME
GET INTO STORES
LIKE BED BATH & BEYOND
AND STAPLES.
AND ROBERT
BROUGHT THE SignalVault
ON "GOOD MORNING AMERICA"
AND SHOWED EVERYONE
HOW IT WORKS.
PUT THIS NEXT TO
YOUR CREDIT CARS.
IT BLOCKS THE RFID SCREEN.
ROBERT AND HIS TEAM ARE
TOP EXPERTS ON CYBERSECURITY.
THEY'VE HELPED ME WITH
SEARCH-ENGINE OPTIMIZATION,
AND THEY'VE HELPED ME
PREPARE MY WEBSITE
FOR THE INCREASE IN ORDERS.
WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS REACH OUT
TO EVEN MORE COMPANIES.
PITCHING ON "SHARK TANK"
WAS ONE OF THE HARDEST THINGS
I'VE EVER DONE.
BUT NOW IT'S CHANGED MY LIFE.
I'M NOW EXPECTING
MY SECOND CHILD,
AND THE RAPID GROWTH
FROM "SHARK TANK"
HAS GIVEN ME
THE CONFIDENCE TO KNOW
I WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE FOR MY FAMILY
FOR THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
WHEN I WALK IN TO MY OFFICE
AND I SEE MY EMPLOYEES,
I JUST GET THIS FEELING
THAT I'VE MADE IT.
AND IT'S ALL BEEN POSSIBLE
BECAUSE OF "SHARK TANK."
All: SignalVault!
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A BUSINESS HOPING TO
EXPOSE THE DIRTY SECRET
LURKING IN YOUR BED.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL INGLE.
I'M FROM DALLAS, TEXAS.
-YEAH!
I'M HERE SEEKING $1.5 MILLION
FOR 15% EQUITY STAKE
IN MY COMPANY, CLEAN SLEEP.
CLEAN SLEEP WILL CHANGE THE WAY
YOU SLEEP AT NIGHT.
WHAT IF I TOLD YOU
THAT THE ONE THING
YOU COME INTO
THE CLOSEST CONTACT WITH
AND SPEND THE MOST TIME ON
NEVER GETS CLEANED?
TAKE A LOOK.
EVERY MATTRESS IS REALLY
JUST A GIANT SPONGE
COLLECTING HUMAN WASTES.
-EW.
-JUST IMAGINE
HOW MANY OTHER PEOPLE'S
DEAD SKIN, SWEAT, SALIVA,
BODILY FLUIDS,
AND WHO KNOWS WHAT ELSE
IS IN THAT VERY MATTRESS
YOU'LL BE SLEEPING ON TONIGHT.
INTRODUCING
THE CLEAN SLEEP MACHINE
AND MATTRESS CLEANING SERVICE.
THE CLEAN SLEEP'S PROPRIETARY
PROCESS IS 99.9% EFFECTIVE
AT ELIMINATING BACTERIA, MOLD,
VIRUSES, DUST MITES,
AND EVEN BED BUGS.
THE CLEAN SLEEP MACHINE
ALLOWS YOU TO INSERT ANYTHING
FROM CUSHIONS TO PILLOWS,
A BABY'S CRIB MATTRESS,
ALL THE WAY UP TO
A CALIFORNIA KING.
THIS REVOLUTIONARY TECHNOLOGY
IS ECO-FRIENDLY,
FULLY AUTOMATED,
TAKES JUST 15 MINUTES,
AND LEAVES YOUR MATTRESS
COMPLETELY DRY.
SO, SHARKS, WHO'S READY TO
JUMP IN BED WITH CLEAN SLEEP
FOR THE BEST NIGHT
OF YOUR LIFE?
-WOW.
-HOW DOES THAT WORK?
IS THAT U.V. LIGHTS?
SO, WE USE U.V. LIGHT.
WE USE
A SUPER-HEATED DRY STEAM.
WE USE A VACUUM
10 TIMES MORE POWERFUL
THAN YOUR VACUUM AT HOME.
WE USE INFRARED HEAT
OZONE INDUCTION,
AND WE ALSO HAVE AN OPTIONAL
ANTIMICROBIAL TREATMENT.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO TRUCKS
THAT ARE OUT RUNNING.
YOU CALL US UP, WE GO OUT,
WE TAKE YOUR MATTRESS,
WE PUT IT IN THE MACHINE,
AND IN 15 MINUTES, WE'RE DONE.
MICHAEL,
CAN YOU DEMONSTRATE THIS?
ABSOLUTELY.
YOU CAN GET A TAN.
THEN WE ALSO HIT IT
WITH A DRY STEAM.
MICHAEL,
YOU INVENTED THIS?
YES, SIR.
SO, ALMOST EIGHT YEARS AGO,
FELL ASLEEP ON MY MATTRESS.
MY SHEETS WERE STILL
IN THE WASHING MACHINE,
AND I WAS GROSSED OUT
BY THE FACT THAT I WAS
LAYING ON MY MATTRESS.
I STARTED DOING SOME RESEARCH
AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
IF THERE WAS ANYTHING OUT THERE
THAT EXISTS
THAT WOULD ALLOW ME
TO CLEAN MY MATTRESS.
AND FOR THE NEXT 7 1/2 YEARS,
I STARTED DEVELOPING
THE TECHNOLOGY,
AND 2 1/2 YEARS AGO,
I STARTED BUILDING THE PROTOTYPE
IN MY GARAGE AT HOME.
-I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS.
HOW OFTEN
DO YOU NEED TO DO THIS?
SO, FOR RESIDENTIAL,
WE RECOMMEND
EVERY SIX MONTHS TO A YEAR.
FOR HOTELS, HOSPITALS,
SENIOR LIVING FACILITIES,
IT'S MUCH MORE FREQUENT.
DO YOU HAVE HOTELS THAT HAVE
SIGNED ON TO DO THIS?
YES, WE'VE SERVICED
OVER 30 HOTELS.
WHAT ABOUT REACHING OUT TO,
LIKE, MAJOR HOTEL CHAINS
LIKE HILTON AND HYATT?
SO WE'VE GOT SOME MEETINGS
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN SET,
AND WE ACTUALLY DID A PILOT FOR
THE FIRST QUARTER OF LAST YEAR
AND SERVICED ONE HOSPITALITY
COMPANY'S MATTRESSES,
AND IN THREE MONTHS,
SAVED THEM ALMOST $100,000.
WELL, I WANT TO KNOW
HOW YOU DID THAT.
HOW DID YOU
SAVE THEM MONEY?
WHAT WE DID IS WE WENT IN
AND WE SANITIZED THE MATTRESSES,
WHERE THEY WOULD HAVE HAD TO
HAVE BEEN REPLACED OR REMOVED.
IT ACTUALLY TOOK THE STAINS
OUT FROM THE MATTRESS?
ABSOLUTELY, YES.
IT'S MORE MENTAL, THOUGH,
ISN'T IT?
LIKE YOU SAID, YOU WERE
LAYING ON YOUR MATTRESS,
YOUR SHEETS
WERE IN THE LAUNDRY.
WHY WERE YOU
SO GROSSED OUT?
THERE'S A REASON WHY
YOU WEIGH LESS IN THE MORNING
THEN WHEN YOU DO WHEN YOU
GO TO SLEEP AT NIGHT.
YOUR BODY'S SWEATING, SECRETING
ALL KINDS OF OTHER THINGS,
SHEDDING DEAD SKIN CELLS.
-WELL, THAT'S WHAT THE SHEETS
ARE FOR, NO?
WELL, IMAGINE
CHANGING YOUR CLOTHES EVERY DAY
AND NEVER TAKING A SHOWER.
IN JUST A MATTER OF A WEEK,
YOU'D BE FILTHY.
SO, CHANGING THE SHEETS ON YOUR
MATTRESS IS THE SAME PRINCIPLE.
YOU CHANGE THE SHEETS,
BUT YOU NEVER
CLEAN YOUR MATTRESS.
HOW MUCH DOES IT COST,
MICHAEL?
SO, OUR STANDARD SERVICE
IS $89.95.
-THAT'S ALL?
-YES.
I THINK
YOU'RE CHARGING TOO LITTLE.
YOU GOT TO GO GET IT
OUT OF THE HOUSE, RIGHT?
RIGHT, SO, TYPICALLY,
WHEN WE GO OUT AND WE SERVICE,
WE ALSO UPCHARGE FOR SPOT
TREATMENTS, STAIN TREATMENTS,
ADDITIONAL
HEAT TREATMENTS.
WHAT WERE YOUR SALES LAST YEAR
OR THIS YEAR?
SO, SINCE WE LAUNCHED,
WE JUST PASSED PROOF OF CONCEPT,
I ACTUALLY SOLD
THE FIRST FRANCHISE FOR $435,000
AND USED THAT
TO CASH FLOW OPERATIONS.
BUT WHAT WERE YOUR SALES
FROM YOUR TRUCK?
OVER THE LAST 18 MONTHS, WE'VE
DONE OVER $100,000 IN SALES
JUST WITH THE FIRST TRUCK.
I'D LIKE YOU TO PITCH ME
AS A FRANCHISEE,
A POTENTIAL FRANCHISEE.
GIVE ME THE NUMBERS.
SO, OUR PROJECTIONS SHOW
ABOUT A $75,000 A YEAR REVENUE
FOR YOUR FIRST YEAR.
ONLY $75,000?
ONLY $75,000.
SO,
WHAT'S YOUR NET ON $75,000?
RIGHT ABOUT BREAK EVEN.
IT SEEMS LOW.
TO MAKE $75,000 OFF
A SINGLE TRUCK,
IT SEEMS REALLY LOW TO ME.
-YEAH, IT SEEMS REALLY LOW.
WHY AREN'T YOU
MAKING MORE MONEY?
THAT'S JUST LAUNCHING,
JUST GOING TO MARKET.
WE'VE DONE OVER SIX FIGURES
WITH THE FIRST TRUCK ALREADY.
AND FRANCHISING
AND THE MOBILE UNIT
IS ONLY PART
OF THIS BUSINESS.
WE'RE IN TALKS WITH HOSPITALS
NOW AND HIGH-VOLUME HOTELS,
AND WE WILL LEASE
THAT MACHINE TO THEM
AND GENERATE RECURRING REVENUE
AND ROYALTIES.
BING! DID I HEAR ROYALTIES?
[ LAUGHTER ]
THEN WE'RE NOT WORRIED ABOUT
OPERATING COSTS,
INSURANCE, THE TRUCK, LOGISTICS.
-RIGHT.
IF YOU WERE TO SELL YOUR MACHINE
TO A HOTEL CHAIN,
AND THAT HOTEL CHAIN SAYS,
"WE CLEAN OUR MATTRESSES
BY THIS SYSTEM."
SO PART OF OUR CAMPAIGN
IS OFFERING CLEAN SLEEP
CERTIFIED BEDS.
SO YOU CAN GO INTO ANY
HOTEL ROOM IN THAT HOTEL,
LIFT THE SHEETS,
AND KNOW WHEN THAT MATTRESS
HAS BEEN SANITIZED.
Corcoran: HOW DID YOU GET INTO
THIS BUSINESS, MICHAEL?
SO, AT 14,
I RAN AWAY FROM HOME.
I HAD $120 TO MY NAME.
AND TRIED TO GET TO
SAN ANTONIO, TEXAS,
AND I REALIZED THAT
I NEEDED MONEY TO EAT,
AND I NEEDED TO HEAD SOUTH.
SO $80 GOT ME TO DALLAS, TEXAS.
I GRABBED A PHONEBOOK.
I TRIED CALLING MY AUNT.
I SAID, "HEY, I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU KNOW ME OR REMEMBER ME,
BUT I NEED A PLACE TO STAY.
I'M TRYING TO GET TO
SAN ANTONIO."
SO SHE CAME AND PICKED ME WITH
MY BLACK TRASH BAG OF CLOTHES,
TOOK ME TO
MY GRANDPARENTS' HOUSE,
AND THAT'S WHERE
I CHANGED MY LIFE.
I REALIZED WHEN I WAS DRIVING,
STARING OUT THE WINDOW
THAT THERE'S TWO TYPES OF PEOPLE
IN THIS WORLD.
THERE'S PEOPLE THAT
WATCH THINGS HAPPEN
AND PEOPLE THAT
MAKE THINGS HAPPEN.
AND I REALIZED THAT
I WANTED TO BE SOMEBODY
THAT WAS GONNA
MAKE SOMETHING HAPPEN.
AND SO FROM THEN ON,
I CHANGED MY LIFE.
AT 16 YEARS OLD,
I GOT HIRED ON BY BOEING
AND WENT THROUGH SIX DIFFERENT
FIELDS OF ENGINEERING WITH THEM
AND DID THAT FOR 5 1/2 YEARS
AND REALIZED THAT WORKING
FOR SOMEBODY ELSE WASN'T FOR ME.
YOU'RE
A MECHANICAL ENGINEER?
UM, THAT'S MY BACKGROUND.
I DID NOT...SECURE A DEGREE.
I ACTUALLY SWITCHED
TO ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
YOU JUST DID THIS STUFF -- YOU
DID THIS ALL ON OUR OWN, RIGHT?
YES. I'VE GOT A MASTERS DEGREE
IN GOOGLE
WITH A MINOR IN YAHOO
AND BING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO...
-WHAT'S YOUR BIG PLAN?
YOU'RE ASKING FOR
A LOT OF MONEY.
HOW ARE WE GONNA
MAKE MONEY BACK?
HOW MUCH MONEY
ARE WE GONNA MAKE?
AND HOW ARE YOU GONNA
GET US THERE?
SO, THE WAY YOU'RE GONNA MAKE
MONEY
IS WE'RE GONNA START
LEASING THESE MACHINES
INTO HOSPITALS, INTO MILITARY
AND AIR FORCE BASES,
INTO HIGH-VOLUME HOTELS.
WHY HAVEN'T YOU DONE THAT
ALREADY?
WE JUST PASSED
PROOF OF CONCEPT,
AND I'M IN NEGOTIATIONS
RIGHT NOW.
MICHAEL, WHAT DO YOU NEED
MY MILLION AND A HALF FOR?
WE'RE GONNA BUILD
A COUPLE OF THE MACHINES
SO THAT WE CAN GO OUT
AND DO A PILOT IN A HOSPITAL.
AND --
-WHY?
WHY DO YOU NEED TO DO A PILOT
IN A HOSPITAL?
SO THAT WE CAN SHOW THEM
THAT WE CAN REDUCE
INFECTIOUS DISEASES,
CROSS CONTAMINATION.
I -- I GET WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH,
BUT AREN'T YOU A LITTLE BIT
TOO EARLY?
EARLY IN WHAT SENSE?
IN THE SENSE THAT
YOU'VE GOT PROOF OF CONCEPT,
BUT YOU'RE STILL
AT THAT INTEREST PHASE
AS OPPOSED TO THAT
CLOSE THE DEAL PHASE.
SO, THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO
BRING ON, YOU KNOW,
PEOPLE WITH STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIPS AND RELATIONSHIPS.
THERE'S TWO TYPES OF
PROOF OF CONCEPT.
ONE IS,
DOES THE TECHNOLOGY WORK?
YOU'VE DONE THAT.
THE SECOND
PROOF OF CONCEPT IS,
IS THE MARKET
GONNA ACCEPT IT?
I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'VE DONE THAT.
-SURE, SO --
-YOU HAVEN'T EVEN PROVEN
THAT THE MOBILE MODEL WORKS
BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T MAKE ENOUGH MONEY.
MICHAEL, WHEN YOU FIRST
STARTED SPEAKING HERE,
I WAS ACTUALLY, "WHOA, I DIDN'T
KNOW MY MATTRESS WAS DIRTY.
I'M GONNA GET ALL MY MATTRESSES
CLEANED."
WE'RE GETTING THIS
RIGHT AT THE BEGINNING,
BUT THE MORE YOU TALK,
THE MORE I REALIZE
I'M A LONG WAY AWAY FROM THE
MONEY AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL.
IT'S NOT THE KIND OF --
-I'M JUST TRYING TO
COVER ALL MY BASES
AND EXPLAIN TO YOU GUYS.
YES, BUT FOR ME,
IT'S FAR TOO CONFUSING
AND A LOT OF MONEY,
SO I'M OUT.
OKAY,
THANK YOU, BARBARA.
YOU SEEMED LIKE A VERY FOCUSED
GUY WHEN YOU FIRST CAME IN.
I KNOW YOU THINK YOU WERE
GIVING ME MORE OPPORTUNITIES.
-RIGHT.
-BUT THE LONGER YOU TALKED,
I SAW LESS OPPORTUNITIES.
-SO, LET ME --
I HEARD TRUCKS,
I HEARD HOTELS,
I HEARD HOSPITALS.
-RIGHT.
V.A. HOSPITALS,
PRIVATE HOSPITALS.
-SURE.
-IT'S TOO MUCH.
IT'S NOT FOR ME. I'M OUT.
OKAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME,
ROBERT.
LOOK, MICHAEL, IF YOU WERE TO
COME IN HERE AND SAID,
"$150,000 SO I CAN SET UP
ONE MORE TRUCK."
I WOULD BE THERE.
YEAH.
"SO WE COULD EXPAND,
AND LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT
THE UPSIDE BEYOND THAT."
-RIGHT.
-SO YOU HAVE LICENSING HERE.
YOU HAVE YOUR
DOOR-TO-DOOR BUSINESS.
AND THEN YOU HAVE
YOUR FRANCHISING BUSINESS.
IT'S JUST TOO MUCH
OF A MISHMASH
BETWEEN YOUR THREE
AREAS OF REVENUE.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, MARK.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
I THINK IT'S A REALLY SMART IDEA
FOR HOTEL CHAINS,
BUT THAT'S GONNA BE
A SLOW, LONG PROCESS.
AND ME, I LIKE TO SEE MY MONEY
COME BACK AT LIGHTNING SPEED.
AND MY CONCERN IS THE HOSPITALS
AND THE HOTEL CHAINS.
IT'S GONNA TAKE YOU
A REALLY LONG TIME.
WHILE I THINK IT'S GENIUS,
I HAVE TO BE OUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
SO, I'M THE LAST SHARK, MICHAEL.
AND I ALWAYS --
ROYALTIES AND RESIDUAL INCOME,
MR. WONDERFUL.
[ LAUGHS ]
NO, I GET IT, BUT YOU KNOW,
I HAVE TO PAY $1.5 MILLION
TO FIND OUT WHAT I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK YOU HAVE
SOMETHING AMAZING HERE,
BUT I'M NOT THERE.
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT.
-GOOD LUCK, MICHAEL.
-THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
-I APPRECIATE.
-GOOD LUCK, MICHAEL.
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE IT. LOOK WHAT
YOU'VE ALREADY DONE IN LIFE.
YOU'LL HAVE A CUSTOMER
IN DALLAS.
APPRECIATE IT.
THANKS, MARK.
O'Leary: MILLION AND A HALF IS
TOO BIG. THAT WAS TOO CRAZY.
YEAH, HE DIDN'T -- HE DIDN'T
SET UP THE DEAL RIGHT.
-TOO MUCH TOO EARLY.
-THAT'S A BAD DEAL.
"SHARK TANK"
COULD BE A GAME.
-GREAT GUY, THOUGH.
-YEP.
Ingle:
I'LL USE THIS TO EMPOWER ME
AND TO HELP ME STAY DRIVEN
AND FOCUSED
AND MOVE FORWARD
AND PUSH THROUGH IT.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A PRODUCT THAT IS FASHIONABLE
AND FUNCTIONAL.
♪♪
[ CHUCKLES ]
HI. I'M SARAH BUXTON.
I'M FROM LOS ANGELES,
CALIFORNIA.
AND MY COMPANY IS TUTUBLUE.
I'M SEEKING $200,000
FOR A 25% STAKE IN MY COMPANY.
I'M HERE TO CHANGE THE LOOK
OF SWIMWEAR.
WE'VE ALL BEEN THERE --
SPENT THE DAY AT THE BEACH,
BOOGIE BOARDING, SURFING,
STAND-UP PADDLEBOARDING,
SNORKELING,
BOATING, HANGING OUT.
WHATEVER IT IS YOU DO,
YOU ARE VERY CAREFUL
TO REAPPLY YOUR SUNSCREEN
THROUGHOUT THE DAY
ONLY TO GET HOME TO FIND OUT
EXACTLY WHERE YOU MISSED A SPOT
WITH A RED, PAINFUL SUNBURN.
WELL, TUTUBLUE IS THE ANSWER
TO YOUR PROBLEMS.
TUTUBLUE MAKES
A FIRST-OF-ITS-KIND,
ONE-PIECE BEACH SUIT.
IT'S MADE WITH UPF-50 FABRIC.
NOW, UPF-50 FABRIC BLOCKS OUT
97% OF THE SUN'S HARMFUL RAYS.
IT'S LIGHTWEIGHT, DURABLE,
COMFORTABLE, DRIES QUICKLY,
AND IT ACTUALLY KEEPS YOU COOL.
SO, IF YOU'RE SOMEONE
WHO CARES ABOUT
THE DAMAGING EFFECTS OF THE SUN,
THEN TUTUBLUE IS FOR YOU.
SO, WHAT DO YOU SAY, SHARKS?
DO YOU WANT TO SWIM THESE WATERS
WITH ME?
[ CHUCKLES ]
-CAN WE SEE THEM, SARAH?
-YES, YOU CAN.
I'M GUESSING YOU ALL
ARE IN THE SAME YOGA CLASS.
UH, YEAH.
[ CHUCKLES ]
HERE'S ONE FOR YOU.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE GONNA LOOK GOOD IN THAT,
ROBERT.
ARE YOU SURE
I DON'T HAVE LORI'S?
YOU WANT TO SWITCH?
[ LAUGHS ]
-HERE YOU GO, BARBARA.
-THANK YOU, SARAH.
NOT MY COLOR,
BUT I'LL ACCEPT.
-OH.
-THE PINK FLORAL PANTS.
BARBARA, JUST TAKE IT.
I'LL GIVE YOU
ANOTHER ONE LATER.
-OKAY.
-SO, SARAH, IT COMES AS
A SHORT VERSION OBVIOUSLY HERE.
-YES.
IS IT A REPLACEMENT
FOR A WET SUIT?
OR IS IT --
-NO, SHE'S PROTECTING HER SKIN.
YEAH, IT'S THE OPPOSITE --
WOULD I WEAR THIS
PADDLEBOARDING?
OH, YOU WOULD WEAR THIS
PADDLEBOARDING 100%
BECAUSE YOU'RE OUT THERE
EXPOSED TO THE SUN, SO...
-BUT WHO'S OUR DEMOGRAPHIC?
-DOES IT KEEP ME WARM?
WHAT AGE WOMAN WANTS TO
COMPLETELY COVER UP HER BODY?
IT'S ACTUALLY IN
EVERY AGE DEMOGRAPHIC.
YES, IT'S PERFECT
FOR THE WOMAN OVER 40.
YEAH?
'CAUSE THE MINUTE
I HIT 40,
MY BOTTOM DROPPED OUT OF
THE BOTTOM OF MY BATHING SUIT.
BUT I JUST WANT TO BE HONEST
ABOUT IT.
IT COVERS IT UP.
IT'S PERFECT.
IS THAT -- WHERE ARE YOU SELLING
MOST OF THEM
IF YOU LOOK AT YOUR DOLLAR SALES
BY AGE?
OKAY, I'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR, UH, A MONTH AND A HALF.
-NO.
-OKAY.
-SO, YOU DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER.
-I DON'T HAVE
THE ANSWER TO THAT,
BUT I COULD TELL YOU, I HAVE
$4,000 WORTH OF SALES, BUT --
NO AGAIN.
IT'S LITERALLY JUST LIKE
JUST STARTED MY BUSINESS.
-SARAH, WHAT --
-LET ME ASK YOU
ABOUT THE PRODUCT
'CAUSE I'M JUST CURIOUS.
-SURE. YES.
-TOUCHING IT, IT'S STRETCHY.
MM-HMM.
DOES THIS HOLD YOU IN,
SUCK YOU IN A BIT?
IT DOES
SUCK YOU IN A BIT.
WHAT DOES THIS
FEEL LIKE ON?
IT ACTUALLY
KEEPS YOU COOL.
THERE'S SOMETHING
ABOUT THE FABRIC
THAT IT DOESN'T ALLOW THE SUN
TO PENETRATE.
I'VE SEEN THIS ON CHILDREN
ALL THE TIME.
RIGHT. BUT LET ME SHOW YOU
MY CHILDREN'S LINE THAT'S HERE.
THE THING ABOUT THE CHILDREN'S
LINE IS KIDS HATE SUNSCREEN.
THEY HATE WET SUITS.
THEY HATE RASH GUARDS.
WELL, THAT'S WHY
THEY HAVE IT ALREADY.
BUT CHILDREN --
ARE YOU THE FIRST ONE --
DID YOU CREATE THIS
FOR A REASON?
-I DID. YES.
-WHY?
UM, A YEAR AND A HALF AGO,
I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH MELANOMA.
AND, UM,
IT WAS REALLY DEVASTATING.
I DIDN'T REALLY UNDERSTAND
THE MAGNITUDE
OF WHAT MELANOMA MEANS.
EVERY HOUR EVERY DAY,
A PERSON DIES FROM MELANOMA.
BUT, UM...
LUCKILY -- LUCKILY, YOU CAUGHT
IT EARLY, RIGHT?
I'M LUCKILY --
I'M A VERY LUCKY PERSON.
AND WHILE I WAS RECOVERING,
I SPENT A LOT OF TIME
AT THE OCEAN WITH MY FAMILY,
AND, UM,
I JUST COULDN'T IMAGINE,
LIKE, NOT HAVING THAT
AS PART OF MY LIFE.
AND SO, I JUST DEVELOPED THIS
IDEA FOR A SUIT.
I THINK
IT'S AN INTERESTING IDEA.
YOU'VE TAKEN SOMETHING
THAT WORKS FOR KIDS
AND APPLIED IT TO ADULTS.
YOUR MOTIVATION WAS FOR
PROTECTION. I GET THAT.
BUT I'M THINKING
COULD IT BE --
AND DON'T TAKE ME WRONG
WHEN I SAY THIS --
COULD THIS BE A COUGAR-TU?
COULD IT BE --
-A COUGAR-TU. OHHH.
-OH, MY GOD.
-LIKE, COULD IT BE SOMETHING
THAT -- THAT IS POPULAR --
POPULAR FOR WOMEN THAT DON'T
WANT TO WEAR BIKINIS?
YOU SHOULD HAVE HEARD
WHAT HE SAID TO ME YESTERDAY.
-IS THAT AN ANSWER?
-WHAT DO YOU CHARGE AT RETAIL?
AND WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE?
-THEY'RE $47 FOR ME TO MAKE.
-OH, SO THEY'RE NOT CHEAP.
RETAIL IS $220.
WOW.
SARAH, DO YOU HAVE IT
IN RETAIL ANYWHERE?
-I HAVE IT IN ONE STORE.
-I KNOW IT'S BEEN A MONTH.
-ONE STORE.
-OKAY, WHERE?
-IN LAGUNA BEACH.
-DOES IT FLY OFF THE SHELVES?
I JUST GOT IT IN THERE,
SO I DON'T KNOW YET.
THERE ARE NO ANSWERS
TO ANY QUESTIONS.
IT'S BRAND-NEW, I'M BRAND-NEW,
I'M A BABY.
BUT ISN'T THAT EXCITING?
DON'T YOU WANT TO
HELP SOMEBODY LAUNCH THIS?
EXCEPT YOU'RE ASKING
FOR $200,000 FOR 25%?
I KNOW MY VALUATIONS
DON'T WORK OUT
BECAUSE THERE'S NO WAY
TO VALUE IT.
YOU DON'T SAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I ONLY GET 25%.
THAT MEANS THE VALUE
YOU'VE PUT ON THIS IS $800,000.
-I KNOW.
-ICHIWAWA, AY, CARAMABA.
-ICHIWAWA!
-YEAH, IT'S CRAZY.
I HAPPEN TO THINK
THE WAY YOU CUT YOUR STYLE
IS FLATTERING
TO ANY FIGURE.
I WOULD DROP-DEAD GORGEOUS
IN THAT PARTICULAR CUT.
-[ LAUGHS ]
-YEAH.
BUT FOR ME, IT'S LIKE
BUYING A LOTTERY TICKET.
IT'S SO EARLY.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF
THE ONE STORE YOU HAVE IT IN,
IT'S SELLING THROUGH.
AND IT JUST HIT THERE, WHAT?
A COUPLE OF DAYS AGO?
-YEAH.
I'M SURE YOU'LL DO WELL
WITH WHATEVER DO.
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT PERSONALITY,
BUT I'M OUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THERE'S ALSO ANOTHER THING THAT
I'M DEVELOPING, WHICH IS --
I DIDN'T HAVE IT TODAY,
BUT I'M DOING A PRINT
THAT'S SHARK REPELLANT?
-SHARK REPELLANT?
-YES. SHARKS ARE ACTUALLY --
YOU'RE DOING A GOOD JOB OF IT
RIGHT HERE.
YEAH, EXACTLY, RIGHT?
AM I REPELLING YOU?
I KNEW THAT THERE WAS
GONNA BE A JAB.
-OUCH.
-I SET MYSELF UP.
THE SHARK REPELLENT
WOULD WORK HOW?
WELL, THE THING IS
IS THAT THE ONLY THING
SHARKS ARE AFRAID OF ARE
POISONOUS FISH AND SNAKES.
SO THE BANDED SEA SNAKE
IS SOMETHING THAT IS --
YEAH, BUT YOU'RE GOING --
YOU'RE -- YOU'RE --
SARAH, IT'S ABOUT YOUR FOCUS,
RIGHT?
YEAH.
BECAUSE YOU CAME IN HERE
WITH A PERSONAL STORY.
YES.
-FITS PERFECTLY, RIGHT?
-YEAH.
BUT THEN YOU STARTED GOING
OUTSIDE OF YOUR HOLY GRAIL.
THERE'S NOT A DERMATOLOGIST
IN THE WORLD
WHO WOULDN'T SEE THE VALUE IN
THIS AND RECOMMEND IT, RIGHT?
OF COURSE. YEAH.
BUT THAT HASN'T EVEN BEEN
ANY OF YOUR FOCUS.
YOU'RE SELLING IT IN THE STORE
IN LAGUNA BEACH.
OH, THE WHOLE POINT
THAT I MADE IT
IS BECAUSE OF
THE DERMATOLOGY REASON.
RIGHT, I GET THAT, RIGHT?
SO, IT DOES
LIVE IN DERMATOLOGY.
BUT -- BUT WHEN WE
MAKE AN INVESTMENT,
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND --
THE EXACT DIRECTION
THAT IT'S GOING IN.
WELL, IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE EXACT
'CAUSE WE CAN BE THERE
TO HELP YOU,
BUT THE MORE DIRECTIONS
YOU GO,
THE MORE WORK IT IS
TO TRY TO GET YOU FOCUSED.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING,
BUT I --
I BELIEVE THAT THIS LIVES IN
DERMATOLOGY FOR SURE, 100%.
RIGHT.
EVERYBODY IS TRYING TO
PROTECT THEIR SKIN.
SARAH, THEN WHY DIDN'T YOU GO TO
A DERMATOLOGIST FIRST?
SARAH, YOU KNOW,
THE SMALLER YOU ARE,
THE SHORTER THE TIME FRAME
YOU'RE IN BUSINESS,
THE NARROWER THE FOCUS.
BUT CAN YOU LIVE IN DERMATOLOGY
AND WATER SPORTS?
YOU CAN, BUT NOT WHEN
YOU'RE ONE MONTH OLD.
OH.
IT'S JUST TOO WIDE FOR ME
RIGHT NOW.
I'M OUT.
LOOK, IT'S NOT EVEN
THE VALUATION THAT'S BAD.
BUT -- BUT IT --
IT'S THE AMOUNT OF WORK
THAT'S BAD.
-BUT I'LL DO ALL THE WORK.
-YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT WORK TO DO YET.
-I PROMISE I'LL DO ALL THE WORK.
I AM SUCH
A HARD-WORKING PERSON.
I'VE BEEN WORKING
SINCE I WAS 14 YEARS OLD.
I HAVE NO DOUBT
YOU WORK HARD.
IT'S JUST I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA GET ALL EXCITED
ABOUT DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS,
AND I'M GONNA HAVE TO...
NO, NO, NO, I'M REALLY GOOD
AT TAKING DIRECTION.
I REALLY AM.
-[ LAUGHS ]
LIKE, I'VE, UM,
BEEN AN ACTRESS MY WHOLE LIFE.
-YOU LOOK SO FAMILIAR TO ME.
-WELL, BY THE WAY,
YOU'RE NOT THE ONLY ONE WHO'S,
UH, THE VILLAIN OF TELEVISION.
-OH, REALLY? YOU TOO?
-WELL, YOU SEE, I AM --
I WAS ON "THE BOLD AND
THE BEAUTIFUL" FOR TWO YEARS
AND "DAYS OF OUR LIVES."
-AND YOU WERE ALWAYS
THE VILLAIN?
I ALWAYS GET CAST
AS THE VILLAIN,
SO YOU --
YOU HAVE COMPETITION.
I LOVE IT.
KEVIN'S A VILLAIN IN REAL LIFE,
TOO, THOUGH.
SO, I AM VERY GOOD
AT TAKING DIRECTION.
YOU -- I PROMISE YOU.
I'M SORRY. I'M OUT.
AW, OKAY.
Greiner:
I THINK IT'S INTERESTING.
I'M NOT LOOKING AT
THE MEDICAL ARENA AS MUCH.
I THINK THAT YOUR DESIGNS
ARE VERY EYE-CATCHING.
BUT IT'S VERY EARLY
RIGHT NOW,
SO FOR ME TO INVEST
AT THIS MOMENT,
YOU'RE NOT THERE YET.
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT, THERE'S JUST ONE
SHARK, MR. WONDERFUL, LEFT HERE.
I THINK
IT'S A REALLY GOOD IDEA
AS A SOLUTION
FOR TWO PROBLEMS.
THE -- THE ISSUES AROUND
COUGAR-ISM AND SUN PROTECTION.
KEVIN, MAKE YOUR OFFER.
MY PROBLEM IS IT'S IMPOSSIBLE
TO MAKE AN OFFER.
YOU SIMPLY ASKED FOR TOO --
-WELL, CAN WE LOWER THE PRICE
IF YOU GUYS --
-NO, YOU CAN'T.
-YOU CANNOT DO THAT.
-$200,000 IS TOO MUCH MONEY.
REALLY?
YOU HAVE TO GET
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO HARD.
IT'S A GREAT IDEA,
BUT IT'S NOT A GREAT DEAL.
I'M OUT.
OH, YOU'RE OUT, TOO?
YES, IT'S OVER.
-SARAH, IT WAS A GREAT START.
-THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU'VE DONE SO WELL
FOR THE FIRST MONTH.
-IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
-THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
-GOOD LUCK.
OKAY, BYE.
WELL, WE CAN DANCE BACK.
EVEN THOUGH I DIDN'T
GET A DEAL TODAY FOR TUTUBLUE,
I AM DEFINITELY GOING FORWARD
WITH ALL KINDS OF PASSION.
I REALLY BELIEVE THAT I WANT TO
GET THIS OUT ON EVERYBODY
AND MAKE THIS THE NEW
BATHING SUIT ALTERNATIVE.
MY NAME IS BENJAMIN STERN.
I'M 16 YEARS OLD, AND I LIVE IN
MELBOURNE, FLORIDA.
AND I'M THE C.E.O. OF NOHBO.
HEY, GUYS. HOW'S IT GOING?
-HEY, BEN.
I LIVE WITH MY MOM
AND MY GRANDMA LOIS,
WHO I CALL "BUBBE."
GO FISH, BUBS.
BUBBE AND I ARE VERY CLOSE,
AND SHE'S FULL OF GREAT ADVICE.
IN FACT, WHEN I FIRST STARTED
MY PRODUCT,
SHE WAS MY FIRST SUPPORTER
AND ACTUALLY INVESTED
IN THE BUSINESS.
I'M PASSIONATE ABOUT
THE ENVIRONMENT
BECAUSE I WAS BORN IN
A GENERATION WHERE EVERYONE
STARTED TAKING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS SERIOUSLY.
POOR BOY.
SO MUCH OF THE U.S.
IS COVERED IN OUR TRASH,
AND A SURPRISING AMOUNT
COMES FROM OUR BATHROOMS.
SO I DEVELOPED
AN ECO-FRIENDLY SOLUTION.
I LOVE THAT I'M ABLE TO
GROW MY BUSINESS WITH MY BUBBE.
IT WOULD MEAN THE WORLD TO ME
TO SEE THIS BUSINESS SUCCEED.
I NEED AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS
SO I CAN GROW THIS TO A PRODUCT
THAT IS SITTING IN THE SHELVES
OF EVERY SINGLE GROCERY STORE
IN THE UNITED STATES.
IT WILL HELP THE ENVIRONMENT,
IT WILL HELP THE WORLD,
AND THAT'S WHERE
I SEE THIS COMPANY GOING.
♪♪
HELLO, PREDATORS OF THE SEA.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NO ONE'S EVER
CALLED US THAT.
MY NAME IS BENJAMIN STERN,
AND I LIVE IN
MELBOURNE, FLORIDA.
NEXT TO ME IS MY BIGGEST
SUPPORTER AND BUBBE, LOIS.
I'M HERE TODAY SEEKING $100,000
FOR A 20% EQUITY STAKE
IN MY COMPANY, NOHBO.
WE'RE CHANGING THE WAY YOU CLEAN
THOSE FLOWING, SHINY LOCKS.
TAKING TO YOU,
MR. WONDERFUL.
YEAH, I NEED THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AS AN ENVIRONMENTALIST,
I WAS SAD TO LEARN THAT
FOUR OUT OF FIVE PEOPLE
ADMIT THEY DON'T
CONSISTENTLY RECYCLE ANY ITEMS
FROM THEIR BATHROOM.
THAT'S EQUIVALENT TO FILLING
ALMOST 1,200 FOOTBALL STADIUMS
EACH YEAR IN THE UNITED STATES
ALONE
JUST FROM EMPTY SHAMPOO BOTTLE
WASTE.
WELL, WITH NOHBO, YOU WON'T NEED
TO THROW OUT
ANOTHER PLASTIC BOTTLE
FOR YOUR SHAMPOO, CONDITIONER,
BODY WASH, OR SHAVING CREAM
NEEDS EVER AGAIN.
THIS PORTABLE LITTLE CONTRAPTION
EXPANDS AND DISSOLVES IN WATER
TO FORM JUST THE RIGHT AMOUNT OF
PRODUCT FOR A SINGLE USE.
NOHBO BALLS LEAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO WASTE AT ALL.
AND BY ELIMINATING
THE OUTSIDE CONTAINER,
NOHBO IS CHEAPER THAN
BOTTLED COMPETITION.
MY BUBBE, LOIS,
AND I WILL SHOW YOU
HOW EASY AND CONVENIENT IT IS
TO USE NOHBO.
BUBBE.
STEP 1 -- RINSE THE HAIR.
-WET THE HAIR.
WELL, YOU'RE SO BRAVE.
Cuban:
BUBBE'S THE BRAVE ONE.
OKAY, UNWRAP THE SHAMPOO BALL
FROM ITS WRAPPER.
DON'T WORRY,
THE WRAPPER'S COMPOSTABLE.
STEP 2 -- PLACE THE NOHBO BALL
ON YOU HANDS UNDER SHOWER WATER
AND RUB IT TOGETHER
TO WATCH THE MAGIC HAPPEN.
WATCH THE MAGIC HAPPEN,
BABY.
TURNS INTO
A REALLY LATHERY SHAMPOO.
STEP 3 -- WASH LIKE YOU WOULD
WITH REGULAR SHAMPOO.
SCRUB AND RINSE.
DON'T FORGET THE RINSE.
CALM DOWN, BUBBE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
OKAY, I THINK
WE GOT IT GOOD ENOUGH.
ALL RIGHT, WE GET IT.
BUBBE, IT'S A JOKE.
YOUR HAIR'S NOW GREEN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SHARKS,
I NEED YOUR INVESTMENT
SO WE CAN LICENSE THIS
CUTTING-EDGE TECHNOLOGY
TO PERSONAL-CARE PRODUCT
COMPANIES AROUND THE WORLD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
GOOD JOB, BENJAMIN.
-NICE JOB.
-WAY TO KILL IT.
WHAT GRADE ARE YOU IN?
I'M AN 11th GRADER.
I'M 16.
MY BUBBE'S 80.
GOOD JOB, BUBBE.
-LOOKS LIKE CHOCOLATE BALLS.
-OH, IT'S INTERESTING.
SO, IT TURNS INTO
A POWDER ESSENTIALLY.
IT TURNS INTO A POWDER
WHICH BREAKS DOWN
TO A REGULAR SHAMPOO PRODUCT.
SO, BENJAMIN, ONE DAY
YOU'RE WASHING BUBBE'S HAIR...
-YEAH.
-...AND IT HITS YOU --
"I NEED TO COME UP WITH
A BETTER PRODUCT."
AND THE IDEA WAS
"I'M GONNA MAKE A SHAMPOO
WITH ABSOLUTELY
NO BOTTLE."
YEAH, JUST LIKE
THE DISHWASHER DETERGENT TABLET.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS THINKING OF
WHEN I THOUGHT OF NOHBO.
HOW LONG AGO DID YOU HAVE
THE BRILLIANT IDEA?
I THOUGHT OF NOHBO
IN JANUARY OF 2014.
IN JULY OF 2014,
I CONTACTED CLOROX COMPANY'S
HEADHUNTER GROUP.
THEY WERE INTERESTED IN
A LICENSING DEAL
ONCE NOHBO'S PATENT
WAS GRANTED.
WE'RE PATENT-PENDING
RIGHT NOW.
YOU'RE KI-- SO YOU JUST CALLED
THEM UP OUT OF THE BLUE.
UH, WELL --
THAT'S HOW HE IS.
[ LAUGHS ]
YEAH, BENJAMIN!
-THANK YOU.
-EVERYBODY SAYS
YOU GOT TO KNOW SOMEBODY.
YEAH, BENJAMIN.
-YEAH, I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW MANY PEOPLE COME IN HERE
AND SAY,
"I NEED YOUR HELP TO MAKE A CALL
TO THIS COMPANY."
AND THERE YOU ARE.
YOU JUST CALLED THEM UP.
GOOD FOR YOU.
-YEAH.
WE'VE TALKED TO
MANY MAJOR CORPORATIONS.
AND SO THEY SAID TO YOU
WHAT?
HYATT HOTELS WANTS SAMPLES
OF NOHBO RIGHT NOW.
HOW DID YOU REACH THE RIGHT
PERSON AT THE HOTEL CHAIN?
THAT WOULD BE A MOST
INTIMIDATING CALL
FOR EVEN A GROWN-UP.
WELL,
I FOUND THE C.E.O.'s E-MAIL,
AND THEN, UM, I TOLD THEM
I HAD A BETTER WAY
FOR THEM TO, UM, USE SHAMPOO
OR CONDITIONER BOTTLES.
SO YOU JUST SAID "I HAVE
SOMETHING BETTER, CHEAPER..."
YEAH.
HE SAID HE WANTED SAMPLES.
DID YOU HAVE THE SAMPLES
TO SEND?
NO.
HOW DID YOU HANDLE THE RESPONSE
TO YOUR E-MAIL?
"SORRY, I DON'T HAVE ANY,"
OR...
I SAID, UM, "I AM CURRENTLY
PRODUCING NOHBO BALLS.
I WILL SEND THEM TO YOU
AS SOON AS I AM ABLE TO."
GOOD FOR YOU.
SO HOW DO YOU GO TO
ACTUALLY MAKING IT?
I CONTACTED A CHEMIST THROUGH
A FREELANCING ADVERTISEMENT.
AND, UH, I GOT A JOB AT 14
TO HELP PAY FOR
SOME OF THE INITIAL EXPENSES
OF NOHBO.
UM, THERE'S ONLY SO --
-ONE SECOND. HOLD ON.
-YEAH.
-[ LAUGHS ]
GET THE JOB
TO PAY FOR THE EXPENSES
FOR YOUR COMPANY
YOU WANT TO START.
YEAH. SO WE ARE INDIVIDUALLY
HAND-PRESSING EACH BALL.
THAT'S WHAT --
-IN YOUR HOUSE?
IN BUBBE'S HOUSE?
-NO, NOT IN MY HOUSE.
THE CHEMIST HAND-PRESSES IT.
BECAUSE YOU NEED
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF PRESSURE.
EVERY ONE OF THESE, AS YOU CAN
PROBABLY TELL, ARE HANDMADE.
COULD A SHAMPOO COMPANY SAY
"WE'RE GONNA MAKE
A DIFFERENT MEMBRANE
USING OUR OWN SHAMPOO
AS A POWDER"?
I MEAN, IT'S POSSIBLE,
BUT A PATENT IS ONLY AS STRONG
AS YOUR ABILITY TO DEFEND IT,
AND I BELIEVE
THIS IS VERY DEFENDABLE,
AND WE CAN BUILD A BRAND --
YOU HAVE IT WRAPPED
IN ALUMINUM FOIL.
TO ME, IT LOOKS LIKE
A CHOCOLATE CANDY.
THAT PACKAGING THAT YOU SEE
RIGHT THERE IS ONLY TEMPORARY.
ULTIMATELY, WE WANT TO USE SOME
SORT OF PLANT PLASTIC PACKAGING
THAT COMPOSTS PRETTY QUICKLY
TO ALIGN WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL VISION.
WHERE ARE YOU
ON THE PATENT PROCESS?
SO WE ARE
PATENT-PENDING.
WE HAVE FILED
TWO PROVISIONAL PATENTS.
HOWEVER,
I DON'T HAVE THE CAPITAL
TO CONVERT THOSE PATENTS
INTO NON-PROVISIONAL.
AND IS THAT THE ENTIRE INVENTORY
OF WHAT YOU'VE CREATED SO FAR?
-UH, SADLY, YES.
-[ LAUGHS ]
-OKAY. SO --
-IT'S EXPENSIVE
TO PAY A CHEMIST.
-BENJAMIN, THIS IS AN IDEA --
ONE SECOND. BEFORE YOU MOVE ON,
CAN I SEE ONE OF THE BOXES?
YEAH, SURE.
WHY IS IT CALLED NOHBOO?
-NOHBO.
-NOHBO?
"NOHBO" IS ACTUALLY
"NO HAIR BOTTLES" SHORTENED.
O'Leary: IS THERE A CHALLENGE
HERE WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
THE MULTI-BILLION-DOLLAR
SHAMPOO MARKET?
UH, THAT'S THE BEAUTY
OF THIS PRODUCT.
WE'RE NOT MAKING ONLY SHAMPOO,
BUT WE'RE CREATING
A DELIVERY SYSTEM.
WE CAN LICENSE THIS TECHNOLOGY
TO MAJOR SHAMPOO COMPANIES.
WE CAN LICENSE IT TO L'OREAL,
WE CAN LICENSE IT TO PANTENE.
SO TELL US ABOUT THE ECONOMICS,
BENJAMIN.
I'VE ONLY GOTTEN
PRICING MODELS
FOR A VERY SMALL QUANTITY
OF ORDERS, WHICH IS 100,000.
THAT'S 6 CENTS TO PRODUCE.
THAT'S THE MATERIAL COST.
MY CHEMIST ACTUALLY HAS
WORKED WITH A MACHINE
THAT CAN LITERALLY SPIT OUT
THOUSANDS OF THESE NOHBO BALLS.
THAT'LL DRIVE DOWN OUR COSTS.
ULTIMATELY, WE WANT THE COST
TO BE AROUND 4 CENTS TO MAKE.
IF WE CAN GET THIS PRICE
DOWN TO 4 CENTS
AND WE CAN SELL FOR 12 CENTS,
AND THESE SHAMPOO BOTTLES
IN HOTELS --
OKAY, LET'S PUT ASIDE HOTELS,
RIGHT? FOR A MINUTE.
-OKAY.
I GET WHY
YOU WANT TO DO IT IN HOTELS.
BUT
TO WHAT WAS SAID EARLIER,
THERE'S A TRAINING PERSPECTIVE
IN A HOTEL.
WHAT THE HOTELS DON'T WANT IS
SOMEONE TO LOOK FOR THE SHAMPOO
AND THEN HAVE TO CALL DOWNSTAIRS
AND GET AN EXPLANATION.
-SO --
-LET ME FINISH, RIGHT?
THE OTHER ALTERNATIVE IS
YOU SELL THEM FOR EVERYBODY WHO
IS ENVIRONMENTALLY CONSCIOUS.
THEY WILL JUST BUY THE PRODUCT
ONLINE, IN WHOLE FOODS --
ARE YOU GONNA LET HIM LICENSE
THIS TO PANTENE OR NOT?
I WOULD LET HIM,
BUT HOTELS ARE HARDER
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
EDUCATE THE CONSUMER.
-OKAY, BENJAMIN.
-YOU ARE BRILLIANT.
-THANK YOU.
-YOU CAME IN,
REALLY AMAZED ALL OF US.
THROUGH MY WHOLE CAREER,
ONE THING I'VE ALWAYS LEARNED --
NEVER SELL SOMETHING
IF YOU'RE NOT EXACTLY READY
BECAUSE
YOU GET ONE SHOT.
I THINK, YOU KNOW,
YOU PROBABLY ARE GONNA BE
FINESSING IT,
PERFECTING IT.
RIGHT NOW, IT'S TOO EARLY
FOR ME TO BE INVOLVED.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I LOOK AT
THE PERSONAL-CARE MARKET.
MULTI-BILLION-DOLLAR BRAND
IS EVERYTHING.
I USE
A CERTAIN SHAMPOO BRAND
TO KEEP THESE BEAUTIFUL LOCKS
EXACTLY THE WAY THEY LOOK.
HOW'S THAT
WORKED OUT FOR YOU?
-IT'S LOOKING GREAT.
-IT FELL OUT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I LOOK SPECTACULAR.
ABSOLUTELY SPECTACULAR.
THIS IS DELIVERY MECHANISM --
THE PATENT IS EVERYTHING.
I KIND OF AGREE WITH
MR. HERJAVEC OVER THERE.
I THINK
IT'S A LONG JOURNEY.
I'M GONNA STICK WITH MY BRAND,
KEEP MY BEAUTIFUL LOCKS,
BUT I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
IF THE PATENT IS REAL,
YOUR OFFER IS VERY GOOD.
I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $100,000 FOR 20%,
BUT IT'S AN OPTION.
I WANT TO WAIT
TILL THE PATENT'S GRANTED,
AND I WANT TO DO
A LICENSING DEAL.
THE PATH I SEE
IS YOU LICENSE IT
WITH AN OPTION
TO STILL SELL
TO CERTAIN SECTORS OF THE MARKET
ON YOUR OWN.
THESE COMPANIES --
THEY WILL MAKE
MILLIONS OF THEM
AT A COST
YOU CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE.
YOU USE THAT MONEY
TO FUND IT,
AND IF YOU WANT,
GO BUILD A BRAND.
OKAY.
THAT'S MY OFFER,
BUT IT'S REALLY AN OPTION.
Cuban: YOU KNOW WHAT?
LOOK, I LOVE IT.
Narrator: TWO SHARKS ARE OUT.
BENJAMIN HAS ONE OFFER
ON THE TABLE FOR NOHBO,
HIS ECO-FRIENDLY SHAMPOO BALLS.
BUT MARK ALSO SEEMS INTERESTED.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
LOOK, I LOVE IT.
ABSOLUTELY LOVE IT.
YOU REMIND ME OF ME, YOU KNOW?
I HAD A GUY, ZACH PILOSOFT,
WHO WHEN I WAS 16,
HELPED ME
FUND MY OWN BUSINESS
AND GOT ME STARTED
AND REALLY DID A LOT FOR ME.
HERE IS MY OFFER.
I'VE GOT TOO MANY LAWYERS
THAT WORK FOR ME,
SO HELPING WITH THE PATENT
IS EASY.
I ALSO HAVE HOT TOT,
WHICH IS A SHAMPOO COMPANY
THAT'S GEARED TOWARDS
YOUNG KIDS,
UM, AND I'VE ALSO GOT KISSTIXX
THAT DOES OEM MANUFACTURING.
IN ADDITION, I'M GUESSING
YOU DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
ACCOUNTING TOOLS BEHIND YOU.
I COULD JUST
TAKE ALL THAT OVER.
ALL THAT SAID,
I'D OFFER YOU $100,000 FOR 25%.
WOW.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
JUST LIKE HE DOES,
I GOT LOTS OF LAWYERS.
I MEAN, I'M SITTING HERE
AND I'M SAYING
THIS COULD BE ONE OF
THE BEST THINGS I'VE EVER SEEN
ON "SHARK TANK"
IF HE GETS A PATENT.
SO I'M NOT LOOKING AT IT
AS A SHAMPOO.
I'M LOOKING AT IT AS A DELIVERY
MECHANISM FOR EXISTING BRANDS.
I'LL GIVE YOU
YOUR FULL PRICE.
20%.
I'M GONNA INTRODUCE YOU TO THE
RIGHT PERSON AT ESTéE LAUDER,
AND IF YOU COULD SELL THEM
AND THEY BUY IN,
I'LL GIVE YOU THE MONEY.
THAT'S A LONG SHOT,
BUT A POSSIBILITY.
IT'S AN ALL-OR-NOTHING
PROPOSITION.
WOULD ANY OF YOU CONSIDER,
LIKE, JOINING?
NO.
I WANT TO THANK YOU GUYS ALL
FOR YOUR OFFERS.
BUT, MARK, WE GOT A DEAL.
LET'S DO THIS.
WOW.
-CONGRATULATIONS, BENJAMIN.
-THANK YOU.
-I'M REAL PROUD OF YOU, MAN.
-THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU REMIND ME OF A MINI-ME.
BUBBE!
-I KNEW -- I KNEW IT.
-MAZEL TOV.
I KNEW YOU WOULD DO IT
BECAUSE I KNEW THAT
YOU'D BE IMPRESSED WITH HIM.
YEAH, AND I WAS.
I REALLY AM.
CONGRATULATIONS.
-GOOD JOB.
-BYE.
-YOU'RE AMAZING.
-BYE, BUBBE!
VERY COOL.
YES!
YAY!
[ LAUGHS ]
Stern: IT'S LIKE
HE'LL BECOME MY MENTOR.
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT I WANTED.
IT'S REALLY --
IT'S BEYOND WORDS.
IT'S LIKE, YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE
WINNING THE LOTTERY BUT BETTER.
YOU EARNED IT!
♪♪